no solo
[Música]
me criaron con la idea
y que tenía que prepararme
profesionalmente que no me quedara solo
con la preparatoria como muchas
velocidad social y mi época
para poder defenderlo en la vida
curiosamente al mismo tiempo me educaron
para que después de estudiar la
universidad y tener esa herramienta de
defensa trabajará un par de años y
enseguida sentará cabeza sí sentar la
cabeza sentar cabeza para mis padres
significaba conocer un buen nombre
casarme y formar una familia
esa era la idea de cuando yo estudiaba
en la prepa las generaciones de antes
así lo veían correcto la sociedad que
todas las mujeres tenían que prepararse
pero al final tenían que formarlo
pues que cree
tuve la fortuna y bendición de conocer y
enamorarme de eso bueno de casarme y
tener dos hermosos hijos que son y que
son
mis padres tenían la firme idea de que
la mujer alcanzar la plenitud al ser
madre
y no estoy peleada con esa filosofía de
aquella generación gracias a ello tengo
mis motores que me impulsan a dar lo
mejor de mí
pero hoy les puedo asegurar que la
plenitud de la mujer depende de cada
proyecto
de sus metas de sus sueños de cómo se
ven de qué quieren para ellas de sus
pasiones de sus deseos de los objetivos
que tengan en mente
cuando la mujer descubre y sabe que
tiene un abanico infinito de opciones
para crecer para desarrollarse para
proyectarse en lo que le apasiona
y puede elegir libremente su camino
les aseguro que alcanzan la punta
al ser madre
nació una preocupación en mí
esta preocupación era de darles un buen
ejemplo que les voy a enseñar a mis
hijos cómo van a ser educados que van a
aprender venir
lo que yo quise en ese momento fue
a dejarles un mundo mejor
que ellos vieron que tenían capacidades
para cuidar y proteger del que estuviera
al lado de ser agradecidos con la
naturaleza con la vida porque si en el
planeta tierra no existimos sin la
naturaleza no existimos somos parte de
él
así es como nace mi organización sin
fines de lucro tenía en los 29 años
cuando inicia este proyecto ecológico ya
estaba grandecita
estaba estudiando la maestría en
gerencia empresarial en ese momento ya
que también al mismo tiempo de ser madre
administrar una fábrica de productos
para la construcción blog vigueta
bovedilla usted es para hacer qué
trabajaba con muchos hombres trabaja con
muchos hombres
me faltaba un año y medio para acabar la
maestría
pero aún así con todas las dudas y
temores porque recuerden que tenía dos
bebés que en ese momento ahorita están
grandes pero en ese momento mis hijos
tenían tres años y medio casi dos
entonces era el miedo las dudas el
tiempo podré lo podré pero que creen que
hice con el apoyo de la familia
me lancé me atreví
a 20
y así di el primer paso
comer seguridad en mi interior
confiar en sueño
en creer que mi meta era buena
escuchemos con azul
mi meta recuerden que es dejarles un
mundo mejor a mis hijos un mundo mejor
del que lo encontramos un mundo mejor
del que tenemos
es un ejemplo de vida del esfuerzo
diario del trabajo
del amor
ya tenía una meta que me dedicaba mi
corazón dejarles un mundo mejor a mi
sitio ahora cómo llegar a ella
cómo alcanzar esa meta
ya que es fácil fácil desconocía un 80
90 por ciento del tema legal en cuestión
de asociaciones viles no sabía nada lo
único que sabía es que una organización
sin fines de lucro que es la que sirve
apoya ayuda si ven sin ver a quien sin
ver como un simplemente apoye
lo que hice fue investigar acercarme a
los expertos de las organizaciones sin
fines de lucro apoyarme en ellos para
crear mi asociación para constituirla
para lograr una organización legalizada
ya tenías
te aclara esa parte ya tenía la
establecida de los expertos legales pero
que creen al mismo tiempo me di la tarea
de contactar a los maestros en la
materia ambiental en sus diferentes
áreas recuerden que es un proyecto
ecológico y lo ambiental tiene
muchísimas áreas es impresionante todo
lo que podemos hacer
cuando los contactos resuma sus
proyectos me uno a ellos para trabajar y
aprender todo lo que ellos hacían
rodearme de expertos tanto en lo teórico
como en lo práctico
a mí me funcionó muchísimo
escucharlos observarlos apoyarlos en sus
actividades
respetando ojo con eso respetando su
trayectoria atenta a todo lo que hacían
a lo que decían como lo hacían en donde
con quienes por una esponjita
pero siempre agregándole un valor extra
a su trabajo
y esencia incluso demostrando mi
compromiso y agradecimiento por todo lo
que hacen en beneficio del medio
ambiente
reconociéndoles siempre su esfuerzo
admirando su constancia y tenacidad por
servir a la comunidad
mi actitud logró ganar su confianza y mi
trabajo ganar su respeto eso es muy
importante
respetemos a los que saben más que
nosotros
para mí es un orgullo hoy en día
compartirles que los ambientales de la
zona sur de veracruz estamos trabajando
unidos
para lograr la misma meta dejar un mundo
mejor del que tenemos no es paz somos
muchísimas agrupaciones muchísimas
asociaciones muchísimos líderes pero lo
que nos une es la meta el objetivo
una de las características de mi buen
líder es la unidad
al decir humildad me refiero a la
sencillez en tu actuar en tu conducta
diaria humildad para aceptar que no lo
sabemos todo y que siempre aprendemos de
todas las personas con las que nos
cruzamos en la vida de todas crean no
importa la profesión el puesto el nivel
socioeconómico su estilo de vida siempre
aprendemos algo de todas las personas y
sus maravillosos
necesitamos su humildad para aceptar que
en ciertos momentos de la vida debemos
retirarnos para ubicarnos para
analizarlos para observarnos para pedir
apoyo debemos aceptar que necesitamos
apoyo que necesitamos ayuda y mucha
inteligencia muchísima inteligencia para
saber a quién pedirla y cuándo pedirla
recordemos que las mujeres tenemos un
gran poder en la palabra que siempre
influyen con firmeza en los que nos
escuchan si les inyectamos nuestra
energía nuestra intensidad nuestra
pasión nuestro amor de verdad que lo
transmitimos transmitimos nuestros
sueños logrando que crean también en
ellos y se sumen a ese sueño se sumen a
la meta y quieran alcanzarla junto
contigo
te invito a que uses tu poder de
convocatoria de liderazgo para motivar a
las personas a ser mejores cada día a
trabajar en su salud mental que hoy en
día es muy importante la pandemia nos
enseñó que lo primordial en nuestras
vidas es nuestra salud mental y nuestra
salud emocional de ahí fluye todo lo
demás a que trabajemos nuestro amor
propio hoy en día el planeta necesita
mejores habitantes mejores seres humanos
y los seres humanos necesitamos calidad
de vida ya no estar corriendo a todo el
tiempo apresurados queriendo alcanzar el
carro más lujoso tener los títulos más
altos debemos aprender a amarnos para
poder fluir y así crecer
en los cinco años que llevo sirviendo a
través de la organización descubrí que
puedo cultivar en las personas el
trabajo en equipo para alcanzar una meta
juntos recuerden que cuando tú apoyas en
el lado avanzamos más rápido y más
fuerte
la mujer creo firmemente y por
experiencia propia que la mujer llega a
tener éxito en el hogar
en el ámbito profesional
en sus metas incluso para su físico y lo
espiritual
en la salud
que la mujer logra potencializar el
proyecto que le pongas en sus manos
porque
porque la mujer es fuerza
es amor
es poder pero es un poder noble un poder
de servicio
cuando un may be there sabe servir a los
demás está avanzando y ayudando a
avanzar a todos al mismo tiempo
la mujer se deben escuchar y si se sabe
escuchar va a poder seguir sus sueños va
a poder alcanzarlos y compartirlos con
sus seres amados sin dejar atrás a nada
se atreve aún con miedos nervios dudas
aún con etiquetas estereotipos de la
mujer no puede ser un hombre la mujer no
puede sola no es cierto
la mujer es uno de los pilares más
importantes en la familia en la sociedad
y lo profesional
la mujer se debe amar a sí misma y creer
en sus capacidades y siempre respetando
a los demás siempre
la mujer como líder sabe servir con
objetividad sabe guiar podemos dirigir
con mucha firmeza
escúchate mujer amante
quiérete
porque siempre vas a poder lograr lo que
tú desees
solo tómate un tiempo un respiro tú
puedes busca en tu interior
tenemos el liderazgo por naturaleza
tenemos ya una familia un hogar sabemos
guiar un negocio una empresa
sabemos guiar una organización
sabemos dar amor y eso es lo que hoy
necesitamos si tienes miedo busca ayuda
porque todas y todos necesitamos del que
instalado muchas gracias
bendiciones
[Música]